♪♪♪
- [Wyatt Teller:] Yeah. Yeah.
- [Tyrann Mathieu:] Oh, yeah! You see that?!
- Yeah.
- Tackle for loss. Thank you!
77 just put me on my ass!
- [Devin White:] I'mma put the dagger in 'em.
- [Joe Buck:]
Brees throws, and he's picked!
- [Jalen Ramsey:] I'mma make him wish
he never said nothing.
- Henne-thing is possible!
- [Announcer:]
The Bills have won it.
They're advancing
to the AFC Championship Game.
- Always put the money on me!
- Welcome
to the playoffs, baby.
- Hey, these games
ain't for everybody!
These games for the elite!
- Just give all you got!
- [Announcer:] So, what a
matchup we have for you here
today at Lambeau Field
to kick off
the Divisional Playoff Weekend.
The No. 1 offense
against the No. 1 defense.
- Ohh!
- Hell yeah!
- [Fan:]
Super excited to be here! Whoo!
- [Za’Darius Smith:] They're what
we've been missing.
Yeah. They're what we've been
missing right here.
- They're the underdogs.
We're just gonna let it all
hang out today.
[Jalen Ramsey:] Don't run.
Just don't run, now.
Make sure you go wherever I go!
- Straight victory, bruh.
- "Win" on three. One, two, three.
- [Together:] Win!
- Live from New York, baby,
it's Saturday night!
- [Announcer:] A showdown
of young quarterbacks:
Lamar Jackson, Josh Allen.
- [Matthew Judon:] Can't nobody on this field
stop you, bro.
- [Josh Allen:] Where y'all from?
- Salt Lake City.
- Oh, OK.
- Topeka, Kansas.
- OK.
- The Bills are winning today!
Let's go, Buffalo!
- We have Buffalo wings
for dinner.
- Our road don't stop here!
- You know
what's about to happen.
- And we here for a reason!
Believe that!
- Bills Mafia.
- [Jim Nantz:]
The Browns last week,
no one gave ‘em a chance
against Pittsburgh.
- [Tony Romo:] Kinda the same
feeling this week, right?
This is against the champs.
- [Chanting:] Here we go, Brownies,
here we go, whoo-whoo.
- [Mathieu:] I know y'all looking for me!
I'm here! I'm here!
- [Tyreek Hill:] Hey, we tryna work.
We at work right now.
We just clocked in,
all right?
Keep the camera on me, dawg,
cuz today, I'm goin’ crazy.
- [Buck:] We know about Drew,
but the guy that's crashed
the party on the NFC side
is Tom Brady.
- This the best seat
in the house.
- Cuz if you ain't amped up
right now for this game...
check your pulse.
- [Drew Brees:] 18 weeks ago,
we stood right here
against this team, and
we talked about being warriors.
Well, one way or the other,
that's what you are!
That's who you are!
That's what we are!
Let's go get a win.
"Win" on three. One, two, three.
- [Together:] Win!
- [Bashaud Breeland:] Playoff football, baby.
It's the only way to do it.
- [Smith:] Win or go home. I ain't tryna go home.
- [Emmanuel Sanders:] I ain't tryna go home.
- [Smith:] Hell no.
- [Sanders:] I ain't tryna go home.
- [Announcer:] Davante
goes in motion to the right.
Quick toss. Davante's got it!
Touchdown!
And the Rams got crossed up
on the motion.
- Jalen Ramsey, ya got burned!
- Hey! Hell yeah!
Hell yeah. Hell yeah.
- [Ramsey:] I want him!
If he go in motion and back,
I can't get on him!
- [Smith:] On the next one,
you gotta hit this.
♪♪♪
- [Davante Adams:] Yeah, all right.
Let’s go.
- [Announcer:] Goff under
pressure. He's sacked.
Za'Darius Smith!
- Yes, sir!
- We have to get pressure
on Brady.
♪♪♪
- [Tremaine Edmunds:] Hey, come on, now.
You know I'm coming now, L.J.
- [Announcer:]
Reverse, goes to Jameis.
And they got a man wide open.
Tre'Quan Smith.
Jameis Winston
with a touchdown pass
against his former team
to take the lead!
- [Jameis Winston:] Little trickery
to get us on the board.
- They was like, "Whoo, whoo."
- [Mitch Holthus:] They're
gonna run a sprint option.
Touchdown, Kansas City!
- [Fan:] He throws it
up into the third deck.
- [Holthus:] Well, whoever
caught it ain't giving it back.
- [Mathieu:] That's why we love him.
- [Laughing]
- Cuz he do it all, Julie.
- [Matt LaFleur:] Whatever you see, man,
I got complete confidence in it.
- [Aaron Rodgers:] I got you, Coach.
- [Announcer:]
Rodgers fakes the handoff,
bootlegs right, pump-fakes once.
- Get in there!
- [Announcer:] Takes it himself
to the end zone.
Touchdown!
- All week long, yo,
"Packers should be scared.
This defense
the No. 1 defense."
But look at your boys now!
Ha ha ha ha!
- [LaFleur:] Good job.
- Thataway, 12!
- Oh, I didn't mean to
click over. I was so excited.
- [Holthus:]
Comes back to the near side.
A man wide open at the 5.
Stumbling for the pylon,
and fumbled out of the end zone.
It'll be a touchback.
- [Fan:] Touchdown.
- [Fan:] No, it's out!
It's out. That's a touchback.
- That sucks.
- Touchback.
- One play at a time.
They haven't stopped us.
We've stopped ourselves, man.
- [John Harbaugh:] Field goal.
- Field goal!
- [Announcer:] 31-yard attempt
for Justin Tucker,
the most accurate kicker
in NFL history.
And the kick hits the left
upright, and it is no good!
- Let's go! Let's go! Hey!
- We good, baby.
♪♪♪
- [Holthus:] Slant. Caught.
Kelce. At the 10.
Touchdown!
- Whoo!
- [Holthus:] A brilliant catch-and-run—
- G-o-o-o-o!
- By the best tight end
in the league.
- Let's go, man!
- Hey, hey!
Let's settle in, baby.
- Hey, dial that thing up.
- [Al Michaels:]
Quick throw here to the outside.
And in for the touchdown
goes Stefon Diggs.
- Yes!
- Let's go!
- Keep ballin'. Keep ballin'.
- Who's gonna be the guy
to break them loose?!
Who's gonna be the guy
to make the difference?!
- [Announcer:] Mayfield.
Play-action fake. Looks.
Throws. Corner. Touchdown!
Jarvis Landry!
- [Announcer:] Kareem Hunt is back in the
end zone at Arrowhead Stadium!
- [Fan:] Run it! His old team!
Let's go, Hunt!
- [Holthus:]
Pass is intercepted!
It's the Honey Badger!
- [Announcer:] Send a blitzing linebacker, and
Brees flushed out of the pocket.
It's a pass. It's intercepted!
Sean Murphy-Bunting.
- Beatdowns! Let's go!
- [Sean Murphy-Bunting:] You get a pick,
you get a pick, you get a pick!
- [Michaels:]
Third down and goal.
♪♪♪
Jackson fires.
And that will be intercepted
in the end zone
by Taron Johnson.
- [Cheering]
- Go! Let's go! Let's go!
- [Announcer:]
Touchdown! Taron Johnson!
- [Cris Collinsworth:]
And the Buffalo Bills
have all of Buffalo rocking
like they haven't been rocking
in 20-some years.
- Always put the money on me.
- [LaFleur:] Oh, beautiful. We're good.
This is what we wanted to see.
- [Announcer:] Rodgers takes,
fakes the handoff,
looks to throw.
- [LaFleur:] Yes!
- [Announcer:] Lazard's got it!
Touchdown!
- [LaFleur:] Whoohoo! Whoohoo!
Hell yeah! Great job, man!
- [Sean McVay:] It's slow motion
for you right now, man.
It's fun to watch you doing your thing.
Seriously. Go do it, man.
- Yeah!
- Let's go, now!
[Laughing]
- I'mma put the dagger in 'em.
Hey, drop on back.
- [Announcer:] Brees.
Brees dropping. It's a pass.
It's intercepted!
Picked off by Devin White.
To the 40.
Shoves a guy out of his way.
Inside the 30.
Devin White down the sideline.
And the Bucs have the ball!
- [White:]
Come on, man! Come on!
- [Announcer:]
The Bucs lead, 23-20.
- [Fan:] Nobody is bigger fan
than me, Papi. Let's go.
Let's go, Brady! Let's go!
- We eatin' Ws.
We'll see you at Lambeau.
- [Buck:]
But if this is it for Drew Brees,
this will be a sour taste.
- Love you, man. Yeah.
- Appreciate you, man. You too.
- We'll be in touch, man.
- We'll be in touch.
- Tom Brady! Good job, man!
Good job, man.
- Look at you
picking that ball off!
- Good job, man!
- [Tracy Wolfson:]
It is official.
The Chiefs will not have
Patrick Mahomes
for the rest of this game.
He is out with a concussion.
- [Holthus:]
Chiefs lead, 22-17.
They have 3rd-and-14
with Chad Henne at quarterback.
- [Chris Jones]: Chad was born for this.
- [Romo:] You're trying
to get this first down, Jim.
- [Nantz:]
Here's Henne. In trouble.
Trying to run for it.
- [Fan:] Chad Henne the GOAT! The GOAT!
- [Fan:] Game over! Whoo!
- [Nantz:] It's gonna be short.
- [Romo:] There's no play.
Just look at the body language.
- There is a play!
- Oh, my God, they didn’t!
- Yeah! [Laughing]
Yes!
- Chad Henne, baby! Let's go!
- Henne-thing is possible!
- [Nantz:] I don't know
another coach in the league
that would have been
that aggressive.
-That's what I'm talking about!
Henne-thing is possible!
How ‘bout those Chiefs?!
- Buffalo,
we will see you next week!
- Get the camera on me, dawg!
That game ended
when they needed me the most!
[Man howling
"Gr-e-e-een B-a-a-ay"]
- I'm not gonna clean it up
because this is gonna be
my lucky shirt.
- Come here, we're going!
We're goin’ to the big one!
- I'm not gonna, I'm not
gonna put ‘em in the dryer.
I'm gonna wear ‘em next week!